uh  jessica where are you going reverend  mother  i was just about to avoid you you gave  birth to a daughter  right if i say no will you be mad  jessica  i am of the benny jesuit anger sadness  these animal instincts have no bearing  over my i gave birth to a son you  [ __ ] what  what the [ __ ] jessica i'm sorry i know i  was supposed to fulfill our creepy  breeding program but  i loved the duke and he wanted a son  what so love is just a thing you feel  now it's what everyone feels  well it shouldn't be please there's  still a chance he's the quizadz hararak  whatever fine you forgive me yes  i mean as long as you're fine with me  poking your son with the scary death  needle sounds good  wait what what  [Music]  you